- On this episode, I'm gonna find out
if you have the goods, the chops, the it.
Redhead quarterbacks, and finally,
me forgetting something.
(heavy bass hip-hop beat)
What's up everybody?
This is Gary Vaynerchuk,
and this is #AskGaryVee, Episode 6.
- [Voiceover] Jason asks,
"What's the best way
"to use Facebook dark posts?"
- Jason, what's up man?
This is a great question
to start Episode 6 with
because it's a general question
that I want everybody to pay attention to.
Jason's asking about Facebook dark posts,
you might be thinking about
how to make Instagram work,
or the up-and-coming amazing
Pinterest CPC ad platform,
or anything, native ads on Outbrain
and Taboola and Hexagram.
The real answer to this, Jason,
is to become a practitioner.
The right price for your ads
is always a moving variable
based on supply and demand,
competition, all that jazz.
The way to become good at it is to do it.
You can go, step one, go
to YouTube and Google,
and look up all the information,
and figure out how to become
better at Facebook dark posts,
read 30 articles on AllFacebook.com about
how to be better at Facebook dark posts.
You can do all the homework,
but until you apply it,
it's just knowledge, isn't it?
And I love students, but only so much.
And so, the answer to
your question, my friend,
is very simple: become
educated and execute.
That's how everything works,
for every single answer,
on all these issues.
To find out the right price,
there is no right price, Jason,
the right price is the right
price right this second,
because of the supply and demand curve
of what you're trying to apply.
If you're trying to sell furniture,
and you're one of two people buying ads
on Facebook dark posts for furniture,
your cost is gonna be a better
deal than in three weeks,
when five people are there
trying to bid that up.
Supply and demand, supply and demand.
- [Voiceover] Dawn asks, "Do
you feel it's still a necessary
"call to action to push
subscribers from social channels
"to a website or newsletter sign-up?"
- Dawn, who says I ever thought it was
a necessary call to action,
'cause the answer is
I didn't, and I don't.
No I don't. No I didn't.
What I mean by that is, sure,
I think it's a good idea
to push to a website right now,
especially if you're selling
something on that website.
But in a world where you
can buy that same product
right on Twitter, right on Facebook,
do you necessarily need to
schlep somebody to your site
to make them buy that, when
it's native right for them,
and they could just buy it in there?
No, the answer is no, isn't it?
'Cause friction sucks, right?
Friction sucks, and consumers
do not want friction,
so anything that allows you to execute
within the place you're in,
that's what you're gonna like.
And so, my answer to your question is,
less and less every day.
People always say, Gary, why
aren't you driving people
to GaryVaynerchuk.com?
Why are you putting
out content on YouTube?
Why are you putting out content on Medium?
Why are you putting content on LinkedIn?
Because I want awareness,
so I'm putting out content
for awareness and to build
relationships with all of you.
That's what I'm doing, and thus,
what that is doing is creating a scenario
where those channels allow me to do that.
Just because I'm not
driving them to my dot--
You know how many people give
you bad marketing advice?
That say, "You have to
drive to your website."
For what? To collect the email?
Last time I checked, a tweet
card that collects email
has been the most efficient
way that I've collected email,
better than driving to my dot com.
For what? What are you, selling
advertising on your site?
If you're selling
advertising on your site,
then maybe that's the thing you could do,
but you can also sell advertising
to people within your social channels
and run that arbitrage.
So the fact of the matter is, Dawn,
is that I think people are
just not really that educated
on what they're trying to achieve.
And so I've never been
worried about forcing somebody
to a dot com, unless that
was the right strategy
at the right time to drive the result.
The fact that even e-commerce,
buying within a tweet and a Facebook post,
has now gotten native the platform,
has eliminated a lot of the reasons
that you have to drive somebody.
- [Voiceover] Nam asks, "How did you deal
"with working in a family business?"
- Nam, very carefully.
Family businesses are difficult.
I'm in my second one, my dad, my brother.
I look forward to my one
with my kids one day.
Misha and Xander, if you wanna
be an entrepreneur, call me.
Um, you know,
I think the real answer is, Nam,
the reason I've had two
successful family businesses,
is very simply, and kudos to my dad,
and kudos to my mom, and kudos to just,
a lot of fortunate things
that allowed my dad and I,
and now my brother and
I, to allow our love
to trump our pride, our competitiveness,
our business POVs,
somehow in our specific situation,
probably predicated
with a lot of hard work,
specifically from my mom,
more than you would think,
and my dad, and then the incredible
natural DNA that they gifted me,
we have created a situation
where we've allowed,
at the end of the day,
for us not to lose focus
on the fact that we love each other
more than we care about getting our way.
- [Voiceover] Nate asks,
"What did you think
"of the Dalton deal?"
- Nate, ironically I'm one
of these kind of people
that actually believe very
heavily in Andy Dalton,
and even though he crapped
the bed in the playoffs,
I actually thought it was a good deal,
I thought they should lock him up,
quarterbacks are tough to come by,
especially redheaded quarterbacks,
that's a big shout out to the redheads,
not the other way around.
And, finally, I just thought
it was a solid signing
that many of you in the
comments section will disagree
and say he sucks and this and that,
and the bottom line is,
we'll see in 10 years.
I will come back to this episode,
go into the comments, and I'll
either give you your props,
or I'll say, told you.
- [Voiceover] Tyron asks, "Does the demand
for your attention get overwhelming?"
- T, very honestly,
the demand for my
attention is something that
I'm so flabbergasted and humbled
and grateful for, I'm
sure it's overwhelming,
I'm sure it's probably
overwhelming right now,
but I'm unable to quantify that
against the enormous pride I have
and thankfulness, and just glee overall
that people actually wanna watch a show
where I give my two cents.
I mean, and I'm givin' three
cents here, motherfuckers.
And so, you know, the answer is,
it doesn't feel super overwhelming.
- [Voiceover] Drekken
asks, "If you had to do it
"all over again today,
would you start with
"WineLibraryTV, or WineLibrary first?"
- Drekken, great question, man.
I've gotta say something,
look, a couple things actually,
before I answer the fine question
and sign off on this show.
Drekken, that's a great
question, but two things.
One, you guys are killing
it with questions.
I'm hitting the hashtags and
seeing these all come through,
I'm completely blown away.
I mean, I was a little
worried that they'd all be
the redundant same questions.
You guys are coming from
all sorts of angles,
so I appreciate it.
And two, you know, this may be a scenario
where some people's
questions who watch the show
every single day are
not gonna get answered
for the first six months,
because of the lottery,
of the randomness, and
so I apologize up front,
keep asking them. Thank
you so much. I'm humbled.
And to answer your question, hands down,
I would do it over again
exactly the way I did it.
Having the comfort that I
built this enormous business
before I started the show,
put myself out there,
in this zany way, and
had that air cover of
respect for what I
accomplished and what I knew,
helped me so much.
If I started the show
when I came out the gate,
when maybe I didn't
know as much about wine,
I didn't know as much
about the wine business,
I didn't know as much about the audience,
it wouldn't have been as good.
You know, chops, skills, the goods,
they have a funny way of
working themselves out.
And so no matter how you roll,
if you can bring it, it's a
hell of a lot more consumable.
I appreciate the questions on Episode 6,
the fun fact for the number 6--
you thought I forgot?
The fun fact for number 6 was,
it was the first roulette number.
There's been a lot of roulette themes--
oh, actually,
that I added to my repertoire
in ten years because I met Lizzie,
born on the sixth, added
it to the repertoire.
Hasn't done that well, Lizzie.
You, with a little bit of me,
we're changing the Q & A world,
whether they like it or not.
Oh crap, wait, subscribe!
(popping noises with mouth)
I need subscriptions,
because I can't push this
many right hooks in social.
So, I know you forgot,
for everybody that waited
for the black screen,
I appreciate the patience,
and I'll see you soon.
Subscribe!
(hip hop beat)
(beep) I want you to go like that,
and then I want you roll
dark for a little bit,
- [DRock] OK.
- like, you know, OK?
You're ready to roll, right?
(hip hop beat)